AS WE
JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
ROBOTATOULLIE, ROBOTATOULLIE.
THEY WERE RIGHT, ROBOTS
ARE HERE TO TAKE OUR JOBS.
MAD SCIENTISTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
MARYLAND TEACHING ROBOTS TO
PREPARE MEALS BY SHOWING THEM
YOUTUBE COOKING VIDEOS.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WE WORK ON.
ROBOTS ARE OBSERVING HUMANS
PERFORMING TASKS.
>> CHRIS: I HOPE THE ROBOT CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE [BLEEP]
THAT GUY JUST SAID.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE MADE OUT
OF ROBOT, THEY'RE STILL
PRETTY DUMB.
SO UNTIL SINGULARITY ARRIVES
THEY HAVE TO DO WHAT WE TELL
THEM.
SUCK IT, ROBOT.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO --
>> YEAH.
I WANT TO YOU COME UP WITH
POTENTIAL NAMES FOR A
RESTAURANT RUN BY A ROBOT
CHEF.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
MARY LYNN.
>> BASKIN ROBOTS.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
GREG.
>> DOMO ORIGATO MR. SABARO.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
EMO.
>> CRACKER BARREL USED AS A
TORSO.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> KFC3PO.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS. SO GOOD.
EMO.
>> I-HUNGRY.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
GREG.
>> TIN HORTONS.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> DINKIN DOUNUTS AND
BOLTS.
>> CHRIS: YES, ALL RIGHT, I WILL
GIVE THAT TO YOU.